is it weird when you go cuz we go to
Disneyland some of our kids right yeah
right yeah all your kids want to see the
princesses yeah obviously so you know
what's it like you running into you they
well let me start by saying I'm a firm
believer that there is no ownership
right but there is the og but okay cool
right I'm og on a first Shore but the
one thing that's weird is that you know
when you talk to them you've probably
experienced this they can't break know
so I go up and we're taking a picture
and I'm like hi Sariah and she's like
arendelle is beautiful today and I'm
like okay she's alright I'll ask Elsa
and I'm like how you doing and she's
like the ice is just melted an Olaf is
thrilled with the summer weather and I'm
like all I want to do is go blink twice
if you need to be rescued it's crazy
it's crazy two adults but the kids kids
love it but it is weird to the yeah and
they're doing this and stuff and they
like like Snow White's my favorite like
and I'm like watch creep don't like it
yes really it's funny but my kids love
it oh the kids don't they don't see
anything wrong with ya a favorite
character my kids would cry yeah I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this